bonjour thierry amouroux merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france alors
on l'a dit un cinq médecins sont décédés
à paris l ap-hp signal 490 cas positifs
au coronavirus parmi le personnel
au moins 230 8 au chu de strasbourg
comment protéger le personnel soignant
basse et c'est très difficile parce que
nous manquons de matériel
vous savez que le gouvernement est
irresponsable de ne pas avoir fait de
stocks stratégiques à la fois de masques
chirurgicaux mais surtout deux masques
ffp2 les masses qui sont utiles aux
professionnels de santé lorsqu'ils sont
contacts pour faire des soins des
patients infectés à l'hôpital et du fait
que l'on n'ait pas suffisamment de
matériel vous savez tout est contingenté
à l'hôpital lorsqu'on prend notre poste
on a droit à deux masques pour la
journée de masques chirurgicaux dans le
libéral les médecins et les infirmières
libérales n'ont droit qu'à 18 masque
pour la semaine donc forcément par le
fait on en vient à être contaminée nous
mêmes donc la majorité des gens n'ont
pas de forme grave
néanmoins un certain nombre doivent
s'arrêter pendant ce temps là ils ne
sont pas là pour prendre soin des
patients
certains sont hospitalisés d'autres sont
réanimation vous avez un infirmier qui
est décédé dans le dans le 77
donc voilà puis surtout ce qui est
terrible c'est que de contaminer on
devient contaminants sans le savoir et
donc on va contaminer les autres
patients de l'hôpital dont on a la
charge
et ça c'est terrible parce que eux s'ils
sont hospitalisés ils sont plus fragiles
et donc le contact avec le corona qui
les russes peut avoir des conséquences
beaucoup plus tragique pour pour nos
patients et tout ça c'est la faute du
gouvernement qui ne fournit pas le
matériel nécessaire pour que l'on se
protège et que l'on ne soit pas
contaminée pour nos patients meurent ou
comment on explique justement cette
pénurie de masques dans le monde
hospitalier aujourd'hui et est ce que
vous êtes réapprovisionner depuis depuis
quelques temps maintenant
alors ça ça arrive au compte-gouttes
tout est rationnée comme je vous le dis
aussi bien l'hôpital camp libéral
et c'est ça qui est dramatique on voit
la conscience d'une part des ministres
qui se sont succédé depuis 2011 moment
où ils ont arrêté de constituer les
stocks stratégiques avec des masques
ffp2 et puis l'inconscience d'agnès vise
un qui nous a fait perdre deux mois
décisif entre le moment où fin décembre
en chine on isole 60 millions
d'habitants
donc si vous moi nous avions été au haut
fonctionnaire ou ministre de la santé
à ce moment là on aurait tout de suite
jeté un oeil sur les réserves
stratégiques vu qu' il n'y avait pas
grand chose et donc lancer une commande
en urgence des défunts descendre ensuite
quand l'épidémie a atteint l'italie ben
là c'était par le risque éventuel que
l'épidémie devienne une pandémie c'est
clairement le pays voisin qui est
atteint donc on était sûr que ça allait
arriver également en france donc là
encore il n'y a pas eu de commandes de
masques de lancer à ce moment là il a
fallu de départ d'agnès bizarre et
l'arrivée du
vos ministres pour que lui réalise que
c'était la cata et ce n'est qu'à son
arrivée que la commande de masques a été
faite fin février
donc on a perdu deux mois et si on
manque de masse
aujourd'hui c'est du fait de
l'inconsistance du gouvernement qui n'a
pas su réagir à temps
c'est aussi le fait que il ya un vrai
problème en termes de confinement alors
un confinement oui mais vous pouvez
sortir faire votre jogging
oui mais vous avez le droit de faire
ceci vous droit de faire ça ça ne ce
n'est pas possible
un confinement doit être totale avec
uniquement une sortie une fois par
semaine pour aller faire ses courses
pour la semaine et non pas aller faire
ses courses tous les jours ou tous les
deux jours
limiter au maximum les sorties c'est
cette mesure barrière qui permet
justement de limiter l'épidémie parce
que vous savez que l'autre gros problème
c'est que depuis dix ans on supprime des
moyens à l'hôpital ont fermé vous
couplez tirer un gros merci beaucoup un
pur pour toutes ces précisions merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur arte
france je rappelle que vous êtes porte
parole du syndicat professionnels
infirmiers snpi merci à beaucoup